are they reality TV stars or dietitians
because I feel like our standard for
good nutrition education sources is
getting seriously skewed hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen today I'm going to be reviewing
a handful of popular celebrity-owned
Wellness food and supplement Brands to
give you my honest thoughts on if
they're a goodbye or total bunk if
you're new here I'm a nobs dietitian so
please don't forget to smash that
subscribe button for more evidence-based
nutrition advice and a check out my
description for a free Hunger crushing
combo ebook but quick let's talk carbs
here specifically bread because your
girl loves her bread there are a lot of
healthy bread products out there and if
I'm honest most taste like cardboard
they definitely do not taste like bread
so I was shocked when I tried my first
loaf of herob bread bread they describe
themselves as real bread with benefits
and that's really exactly how I see
their products too hero Bread is made
with real olive oil wheat plant-based
protein and flax with 5 to 11 gram of
protein and tons of fiber from Prebiotic
resistant starch they have sandwich
bread buns tortillas Brio sliders even
croissants like I've never seen a
croissant with health benefits but again
I don't really care if a food is the
equivalent of a multivitamin if it
doesn't doesn't taste good it's not for
me but believe me when I say this bread
is so soft and fluffy the seated bread
is perfect for sandwiches and the
tortillas are amazing for breakfast
wraps and like most of you herob bread
has some near intentions that they've
set they want to improve their heart
health with their olive oil Rich recipes
they want to make more buttery delicious
croissants which you know I'm here for
and they want to come up with new
Innovative bread products please can we
do pizza dough just saying but we
already know how important protein and
fiber are in my Hunger crushing combo
and herob bread is such a foolproof way
to get both so if you want to try out
herob bread yourself definitely hit up
my description for my link herob breed
is offering all of my followers 10% off
of their first order if you go to
hero. slabby and use my code Abby so
according to report by jll research
celebrities these days have been very
busy doing some things that they are
maybe not technically qualified to do
but nearly 60% of celebrity brands on
the market today were founded in the
last 6 years and I mean that makes total
sense with the rise of social media and
marketers ability to use user data
celebs went from being paid by a brand
to endorse a brand or appear in their
commercial to then realizing why endorse
someone else's products when I can use
my celebrity status and be the face of
my own and I mean I think that's a
really great move in my
books Kim K didn't become a billionaire
being the front of someone else's
panties now even though we sometimes get
to see BTS marketing content suggesting
that these celebs are super Hands-On it
is really impossible to know if this is
just for show or if they are
legitimately heavily involved I mean
remember the time that Kylie Jenner got
called out for staging pictures of her
creating makeup magic it was a super
cute photo op but it really didn't bode
well for her legitimacy and Trust even
if she is actually heavily involved in
her makeup company and I'm sure that
they're all on the important calls and
are testing to give the final thumbs up
but unless they're like hiding their
chemistry degree on their CV there's a
good chance that their R&D involvement
is relatively low lift and how could
that not be like I'm sure the
Kardashians know what probiotics are but
do they understand how different unique
strains perform in different mediums and
do they know exactly how many cfus you
need or do they know how to interpret
high quality research on ingredients I
mean this stuff actually matters but
speaking of the Kardashian Empire let's
take a look at Courtney Kardashian's
recent supplement brand lemi so
Courtney's quickly expanding vitamin
Empire has 12 different products at the
time of filming there are way too many
to get into individually here so I
thought I would Zone in on one of their
alleged best sellers the ly
perr AKA a probiotic for your lady flow
I mean whether or not Corney was
actually Hands-On this one feels
definitely on brand but with a zippy
pineapple flavor purr promises to
support healthy vaginal pH balance and
improve the smell and taste of Little
Miss minky
M I'm intrigued so one serving of
gummies contains 1 billion cfus of
basilis coagulin snz 1969 plus 20 Mig of
vitamin C and some pineapple powder
assumedly for flavor fun fact but it was
allegedly Kim K who like started the
bunk rumor that pineapples make your
kitty taste sweet but believe it or not
there's no evidence that it works nor
should we really want our lady flower to
be smelling like flowers I mean it's all
right like as for the active ingredients
snz
1969 is a really great spore-based
probiotic largely studied for IBS and
digestion but there's only one study to
my knowledge that evaluated its efficacy
for vaginal Health this study looked
specifically at women with a yeast
infection and found that a combination
of the probiotic plus an antibiotic
improves symptoms faster than an
antibiotic alone which makes total sense
to me since antibiotics can be really
tough on our microflora and ultimately
probiotics I can help that but if you
don't have a yeast infection and you're
not taking antibiotics for it I really
wouldn't count on your basic Carnation
miraculously blossoming into a fragrant
summer rose if you get what I'm saying
now it also contains 20 Mig of vitamin C
which is kind of sort of associated with
improved vaginal microflora but the dose
needed for that is over 10 times what is
in your gummies and you're supposed to
insert it like a suppository not chew it
like a piece of candy you get away from
my no so again not really sure this will
do now generally speaking I don't love
gummy vitamins since most gummies need
to be sprayed with the vitamins which
can lead to huge inconsistencies and
stability challenges which is one of the
reasons why when tested gummy
multivitamins tend to score really
really poorly reality is I don't think
these gummies can do harm like I said I
love basilis coagulant probiotics but in
my opinion as a dietitian the probiotic
is really the only functional ingredient
here and it's functional for reasons
completely unrelated to a nicer smelling
vag and to pay $42 for literally just 1
billion cfus which is honestly not a lot
and may or may not be super stable in
gummy form seems honestly quite criminal
to me so sadly no the let me purr does
not pass my sniff test
but moving on to a wellness food product
let's talk about goodles by galado so if
you're a craft mac and cheese lover or
what US Canadians call KD this healthier
box mac and cheese from founder galado
sounds like an answered prayer but is it
too good to be true well let's take a
look so goodles which I guess I figure
is like a word play on Good noodles is
made from a combination of wheat and
chickpea protein along with whole food
vitamins from a wide range of different
fuits veggies and seeds and the cheese
is made from real dairy in the original
and cashews and nutritional yeast in the
vegan version the result here is a box
mac and cheese with 270 calories 7 G of
fiber and 15 g of protein per serving
along with a wide range of
micronutrients it's not like a complete
multivitamin by any means but I would
say it's a pretty good start I'm I mean
especially love that we've got some
calcium vitamin D and iron now the OG KD
has an extra 100 calories per serving
and only has 2 G of fiber and 11 g of
protein now it doesn't offer nearly as
many nutrients but interestingly some of
the nutrients it does contain are
offered in slightly higher amounts so
for example 46% riboflavin in KD versus
25% in the goles but generally speaking
the nutrients that KD contains are not
really nutrients of concern at least to
me so goodles does have an obvious
nutritional Edge I've also tried these
and I do think that they are
legitimately pretty damn good so goodles
are definitely Abby approved though if
you love your KD and let's be honest
sometimes that fake cheese flavor is all
that will do so my tip is to try amping
it up with some steamed broccoli or
cauliflower for some Fiber and some
leftover chicken or ped cottage cheese
for some protein all right folks moving
on to kinu Forex by Bella Hadid if you
went a bit crazy on the festive
cocktails this holiday season and are
resolving to cut back on your alcohol
consumption you might be looking for
some non-alcoholic bevies to switch
things up bellah hadid's kinu Forks
claims to be a non-alcoholic functional
beverage designed using adaptogens to
help you manage stress neut Tropics for
brain cognition and spirit centered
Botanicals to elevate taste some lofty
claims for Like a Virgin drink mix so
let's take a look there are a number of
products now in their lineup but let's
focus on the OG high road which is
described as helping you conjure
captivating conversation and release
contagious energy that flows out to
those around you and reverberates Beyond
what okay so naturally all the
functional ingredients are piled
together in a proprietary blend and
while these ingredients definitely have
powerful benefits I am skeptical of
their efficacy in a product like this so
according to their website they add Gaba
to reduce stress even though a
systematic review found very limited
evidence that it has any stress
relieving benefits and if it does
studies are using doses up to 100 mg or
more can also includes the adaptogen
riola to apparently Boost energy and
vibrancy the energy claim yes but
vibrancy kind of just Mar marketing BS
riola has been shown to have benefits
for stress and fatigue though the
research we do have requires a pretty
high dose of around 400 mg and then we
have 5 HTP in there to apparently
Elevate Joy I don't know who wrote this
website copy but I assume this is like a
super wooy non-scientific way to say
that increases serotonin and reduces
symptoms of depression which 5htp is
actually very effective at doing but
again the dose is usually between 300
and 500 milligrams and if we look at
this
595 milligram proprietary blend that
contains these three active ingredients
plus an additional five ingredients in
the mix and then compare it to the
combined 1,000 mgram clinical dose I
just described it is very unlikely that
any of the active ingredients are
anywhere close to their clinical dosages
translation probably not going to do
that said if you like the taste and
you're trying to cut back on booze maybe
it is worth the $40 USD for eight
servings but if you're looking for
legitimate stress energy and mood
boosting benefits you are much better
off buying these supplements at full
dose or experimenting with non-s
supplement options like exercise and
meditation so yeah this one's getting
the P for me now moving on to Kate
Hudson's In Bloom supplement line first
of all I love The Branding and I mean
Kate is a natural beauty so it's really
not surprising that her products do well
but let's take a look at her
best-selling immune defense blend first
off don't love the slightly dishonest
marketing I mean nothing will boost your
immune system and if it did all these
celebrities would have debilitating
autoimmune disorders because that is
what happens when your immune system is
working on overdrive but moving on in
Bloom's immune blend basically consists
of a handful of antioxidant Rich vital
ingredients including Acero astralis
Elderberry Licorice and ginger and
honestly I think all of these are pretty
great picks for immune support asera is
largely going to be contributing the
antioxidants and the mega dose of
vitamin C we see here which by the way
you are mostly just peeing out and then
astrologus and Elderberry do offer some
evidence for immune support but at
relatively very high doses less is known
in highquality human research on
licorice ginger for immune and infection
protection ction but data on mice fish
and test tubes show that licorice may
offer some powerful immune support and
while the human research suggested it
may improve upper respiratory tract
infections patients were given a high
does Ivy drip not an oral supplement
same with ginger I mean Ginger is packed
with anti-inflammatory and antioxidant
power that enhance our immune responses
in test tubes and animals but we
actually don't have any highquality
human evidence that actually prevent
vents infections or illnesses that
doesn't mean that these things don't
work they probably all do help but if I
were to add up the clinical doses of all
of these potential immune modulators we
would be looking at between 7,000 to
13,000 milligrams which might be
significantly less than what is in this
proprietary blend now the better immune
supporting bang for your buck is
actually in the trio of immune
supporting nutrients it has so vitamin C
vitamin D and zinc honestly she could
have just sold the supplement with those
three vitamins for a fraction of the
price and it probably would work more or
less the same so yeah I will technically
call this Abby approved because I think
it does contain some key nutrients that
probably does help to support a healthy
immune system but at $69 per small jar I
do think it would have been better to
have higher clinical doses of fewer
functional ingredients but if you guys
are curious about any kind of specific
celebrity backed Wellness brand
definitely leave me a comment below I
will try to get to it in an upcoming
episode and on that note folks that's
all that I have for you guys today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up don't forget to subscribe
hit up my description for a free Hunger
crushion combo ebook and I will see you
next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye